[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
Barbara halweg guten Abend schön dass
Sie dabei sind wie auch Norbert Lehmann
für den
Sportthemen von heute
harte Kante gegen Russland die G20
wollen auf ihrem Gipfel den Angriff auf
die Ukraine verurteilen und dabei
ausdrücklich von einem Krieg sprechen
8 Milliarden Menschen so viele Lebens
seit heute auf der Erde und vor allem in
Afrika und Asien werden es immer mehr
und aus der Traum vom Eigenheim viele
die eigentlich kaufen wollten müssen
wegen der Inflation und steigender
Zinsen nun doch mieten und das wird
immer teurer
[Musik]
fast neun Monate nach dem Angriff auf
die Ukraine Gerät Russland auf dem G20
Gipfel zunehmend unter Druck selbst
bisherige Unterstützer wie China und
Indien haben dem Entwurf einer
Abschlusserklärung zugestimmt die den
Krieg aufs Schärfste verurteilt
gefordert wird der sofortige Abzug aus
der Ukraine aus Bali berichtet MRT
wissen
sie trommeln zur Erbauung der Gäste beim
festlichen Dinner aber es sind die
Trommeln des Krieges die den G20-Gipfel
überschatten
die Ohren mussten Außenminister lavrov
klingenden alle anderen sehen die
russische Aggression als größte
Bedrohung für die Weltwirtschaft der
Gastgeber sprach Tacheles
and wir müssen diesen Krieg beenden wenn
der Krieg nicht endet wird jeder
Fortschritt für die Welt schwierig
ein Ende des Krieges sei möglich so der
ukrainische Präsident selenski per Video
schalte die russischen Truppen müssten
abziehen die Unversehrtheit der Ukraine
wiederhergestellt werden ein Riss zeigt
sich trotz dieser Bilder zwischen
Russland und China denn Peking wollte
eine scharfe Verurteilung des Krieges in
der gipfelerklärung nicht verhindern la
worauf muss widerwillig akzeptieren
der Westen hat den Satz hinzugefügt dass
viele Delegationen der G20 Russland
verurteilen und wir haben aufgeschrieben
dass es eine Alternative Sichtweise gibt
wir finden das reicht Russland wenn die
Länder globalen Südens auf seiner Seite
aber die leiden am meisten unter den
Nahrungsmittel und energiekrisen
deswegen hoffen auch Sie auf ein Ende
dieses Krieges mein Eindruck aus vielen
Gesprächen mit vielen der Länder die
sich bei der UN-Generalversammlung
enthalten haben ist nämlich dass viele
davon
innerlich überzeugt sind dass dies ein
ungerechter Krieg ist und ein
überflüssiger
Sergej love jedenfalls verließ Bali
vorzeitig so dass der Rest des Gipfels
so harmonisch werden könnte wie das Ende
dieses ersten Tages
auf Bali ist es jetzt zwei Uhr nachts
Chuck unter Lab energy hält für uns die
Stellung konnte leider der russische
Außenminister ist schon wieder abgereist
zu unangenehm
ja das kann kein einfacher Tag gewesen
sein für das Sergej la for auf der
russische Außenminister der ja hier
Putin vertreten musste der selber nicht
angreifen nicht nur seinen üblichen
politischen Gegnern in der
internationalen Arena gegenüber sondern
er hat auch bei denen auf Granit
gebissen die bisher eigentlich eine
einseitige Verurteilung Russlands im
Zusammenhang mit dem ukrainekrieg
ablehnen selbst die wohlgesonnenen unter
diesen Ländern wie zum Beispiel Indien
und Südafrika haben heute eines klar
gemacht für eine Fortsetzung der
Kriegshandlungen in der Ukraine hat
Russland keinerlei Unterstützung bei den
wichtigsten Industrie- und
Schwellenländern dieser Welt das kann
man schon als Einschnitt bezeichnen
diesen Gipfel und dieses Ergebnis wenn
es dann morgen bestätigt wird was das am
ukrainekrieg ändern wird das ist noch
nicht klar aber das hier dürfte heute
einer der schwierigsten Tage in der
Karriere das gewesen sein
die Einschätzung vom G20-Gipfel
dankeschön
allen Forderungen des Gipfels zum Trotz
hat Russland heute große Teile der
Ukraine mit Raketen angegriffen Ziel war
offenbar die kritische Infrastruktur
mehr als 7 Millionen Haushalte sind nach
ukrainischen Angaben ohne Strom sogar in
der benachbarten Republik Moldau viel
der Strom aus in der Hauptstadt Kiew
schlugen russische Raketen in zwei
Wohnhäuser ein mindestens ein Mensch kam
ums Leben Beschuss gab es etwa auch nahe
Lemberg das ukrainische Präsidentenbüro
sagt die Energieversorgung sei nun
kritisch
in der Hebestreit in Odessa ist das
moskausantwort auf die G20 Forderungen
Barbara das liegt jetzt der Zeitpunkt
zumindest nah 90 Raketen hat Russland
abgefeuert Raketen und drohen das sind
deutlich mehr als beim bislang stärksten
Angriff auf die Infrastruktur der
Ukraine Anfang Oktober die meisten
konnte die hiesige Luftabwehr zwar
ausschalten doch trotzdem sind die
Folgen immens ihr habt das gerade
gezeigt die Stromversorgung ist in
weiten Teilen des Landes erheblich
eingeschränkt nun warum heute der Abzug
aus creason der Schmerz die Russen doch
offenkundig sehr eine war vielleicht
auch ein Zeichen der Stärke auch nach
innen nach Russland nötig außerdem soll
es in den nächsten Tagen hier sehr kalt
werden wenn die Menschen nicht heizen
können dann werden sie frieren keine
Energie heißt frieren und
Ungemütlichkeit und drittens hat Putin
damit ganz klar gemacht was er von den
Aufrufen das G20-Gipfels auf Bali hält
nämlich offenkundig nichts Dankeschön
nach Odessa Henna Hebestreit
nach Deutschland rund fünfeinhalb
Millionen Menschen beziehen Hartz IV ab
Januar sollen sie stattdessen das höhere
Bürgergeld erhalten damit das noch
klappt geht die Regierung jetzt auf die
Union zu denn die hat das Bürgergeld im
Bundesrat blockiert ihre Ansicht nach
setzt es falsche Anreize wie ein
Kompromiss aussehen könnte zeigt Jana
zimmermann
wenn zwei sich streiten muss Christian
dörlinger Arbeiten der FDP-Politiker ist
eines von 16 Mitgliedern des
Vermittlungsausschusses und der muss nun
ran gestern hatte die Union das
Bürgergeld im Bundesrat scheitern lassen
sie blieb bei ihrer Kritik dass ich
arbeiten mit dem Bürgergeld nicht mehr
lohne bis zum 25 November soll der
parteiübergreifende
Vermittlungsausschuss nun einen
Kompromiss finden Christian dürr wirft
einen Köder aus wir müssen eben die
Arbeitsanreize erhöhen und das ist der
Kern dieser bürgergeldreform darum geht
es dass es sich lohnt zu arbeiten das
ist sich lohnt von der Couch aufzustehen
und einen Job anzunehmen Ausbildung
anzufangen und da müssen wir doch
eigentlich mit der Union zusammenkommen
können zu wenig Arbeitsanreize und zu
wenig Sanktionen das ist die kernkritik
der Union wird man sich nun darauf
einigen dass wir zum Bürgergeld dazu
verdient noch mehr für sich behalten
kann oder soll es in der sechs monatigen
vertrauenszeit doch wieder mehr
Sanktionen geben wird das schon Vermögen
von 60.000 Euro pro alleinstehendem
reduziert
auch von unionsseite wird schon vorab
signalisiert wo der Kompromiss liegen
könnte
eine Möglichkeit sofort auch
Fehlverhalten zu sanktionieren ist eine
wesentliche Voraussetzung dieses Gesetz
zustimmungsfähig zu machen das haben die
Unionsländer deutlich erklärt bis dahin
will die Union nur der Erhöhung der
Regelsätze zustimmen mehr Geld ohne
Reform aber lehnt die Regierung ab
Millionen Hartz IV Empfänger bangen ob
sie zum ersten Januar
bürgergeld-empfänger werden und also 50
Euro mehr bekommen oder nicht
im Tarifstreit in der Metall- und
Elektroindustrie wird es langsam ernst
die IG Metall beharrt auf ihrer
Forderung von 8% mehr Geld und
mobilisiert auch heute wieder wie seit
mehr als zwei Wochen mit warenstreiks
bei den arbeitgeberern gibt es noch
keine Bewegung sie bieten
Einmalzahlungen und einen noch nicht
bezifferte Lohnerhöhung es drohen
Urabstimmungen und flächenstreiks Petra
Neubauer
[Musik]
die 8 die sie da fordern steht für 8%
mehr Lohn Tausende gehen dafür alleine
Nürnberg heute auf die Straße wollen den
Druck noch einmal erhöhen damit nicht
alle Leute in der Armut landen die
gerade aber eigentlich vollzeitarbeiten
die Dieselpreise sind geschieden die
Mieten sind gestiegen Gases gestiegen
die Leute brauchen das Geld zum Leben so
machen sie sich dafür stark dass sich
die Lohnerhöhungen in den
Gehaltstabellen niederschlagen heißt auf
eine Einmalzahlung wollen sie sich nicht
einlassen das aber haben die Arbeitgeber
angeboten deren Hauptargument im
Tarifstreit viele kleinere Unternehmen
würden ums Überleben kämpfen man muss
wissen dass voraussichtlich in diesem
Jahr mehr als 40 Prozent unserer
Mitgliedern eine nette Rendite unter
zwei Prozent bis ins Negative haben
unter der Auftragsbestand sinkt und das
Jahr 2023 wird sehr sehr schwierig
Deutschland könnte eine Rezession mit
großen Unsicherheiten drohen das bei den
Tarifabschlüssen berücksichtigt werden
raten Wirtschaftsexperten beide Seiten
könnten Leben mit einer ordentlichen
Einmalzahlung so dass erstmal eine
Lohnerhöhung vorhanden ist aber
vielleicht nicht dauerhaft sondern dass
man dann nächstes Jahr noch mal guckt
wenn man weiß ob die Rezession kommt wie
schwer sie ausfällt und wie die
Unternehmen betroffen sind dass man dann
noch mal entscheidet
am Beschäftigten wieder die Arbeit
niederlegen dann aber länger oder gar
unbefristet
wir sind jetzt 8 Milliarden Menschen auf
der Erde nach Berechnungen der Vereinten
Nationen haben wir heute diese Grenze
überschritten zu Beginn des 19
Jahrhunderts waren es noch eine
Milliarde dann dauerte es bis 1927 bis
sich die Bevölkerung verdoppelt hatte
besonders rasant geht es seit 1960 nach
oben von 3 Milliarden auf 8 Milliarden
in nur 62 Jahren der Höhepunkt des
Wachstums könnte 2018 erreicht sein mit
10,4 Milliarden Menschen im kommenden
Jahr ist nicht mehr China das
bevölkerungsreichste Land sondern Indien
von dort berichtet Norman Odenthal
es ist ein Junge ein Sohn ein
Stammhalter damit ist das Glück für Sony
perfekt und die Familie komplett ich
habe schon eine Tochter und jetzt auch
einen Sohn die Ärztin sagt wir sollten
nicht mehr als die zwei bekommen mein
Mann ist Bauarbeiter es wäre schwer für
mehr Kinder zu sorgen
guten Morgen liebe Patientinnen grüßt
sie mal Ciao Hahn und kommt dann schnell
zur Sache sie könnte Windeln verteilen
für die Neugeborenen aber sie hat
Kondome für die Mütter nimm erstmal die
zur Verhütung in ein paar Wochen hast du
dich von der Geburt erholt dann kommst
du wieder und wir sprechen über
Familienplanung
Methoden gibt es viele das Ziel ist
immer gleich keine weiteren Kinder
es ist eine Frage der Bildung besser
Gebildete planen eine Familie
sorgfältiger ungebildete und das sind
oft ärmere brauchen Beratung damit Sie
verstehen Familienplanung ist eine gute
Sache
bislang wächst Indien eher ohne Plan in
Kürze wird es das bevölkerungsreichste
Land der Welt sein vor China 1,4
Milliarden Inder von 8 Milliarden
Erdenbürgern insgesamt
der riesige demografische Zuwachs wurde
lange als ökonomischer Vorteil
betrachtet aber es hat sich
herausgestellt dass es eine ökonomische
Belastung ist von den zahlreichen jungen
Leuten in Indien bleiben viele
arbeitslos und chancelos
Bildung für alle wie soll das gehen
Nahrung Wasser Energie woher solls
kommen wohin mit dem Müll wie den
verkehrbändigen fragen über Fragen und
dabei hat das Leben gerade erst begonnen
in China ist es wegen der strengen
corona-maßnahmen erneut zur
Ausschreitungen gekommen aufgebrachte
Textilarbeiter Rissen in der
südchinesischen Millionenmetropole Gang
zu Absperrgitter nieder laut
Medienberichten kamen viele aus der
Quarantäne zurück durften aber wegen
eines kobit-ausbruchs nicht in ihre
Unterkünfte seit Wochen wächst in China
der Unmut über die harte
nullkovic-politik
schauen wir auf die Gasversorgung in
Deutschland die gute Nachricht die
Speicher sind zu 100% gefüllt und die
Großhandelspreise gehen runter eine
Folge Tanker mit Flüssiggas ankern vor
Europas helfen und warten auf höhere
Preise die Spezialschiffe können bald
auch Wilhelmshaven anlaufen denn da
wurde heute der Anleger am ersten
deutschen flüssiggasterminal eingeweiht
Fabian Köhler hat mehr
zufriedene Gesichter bei Politik und
Wirtschaft im Rekordtempo ist ein Teil
der wichtigsten Baustelle Deutschlands
der Anleger fertig Bauzeit rund 7 Monate
was sonst viele Jahre dauert Mitte
Dezember soll das Terminal komplett
angeschlossen sein ein Spezialschiff
wird ein flüssiges LNG von Tankern in
gaswandeln und ins Netz einspeisen wir
rechnen mit einer Gesamtkapazität des
Terminals von ungefähr 5 Milliarden
Kubikmeter pro Jahr damit Sie sich das
vorstellen können pro Tanker kann man
zwischen 50.000 und 90.000 Haushalte
versorgen so dass wir hier von einer
Versorgung von ca 2,5 Millionen bis 5
Millionen Haushalten in Deutschland
sprechen rund 30 dieser LNG-Tanker
lauern aktuell vor der europäischen
Küste sie warten auf einen guten
Zeitpunkt um ihre Fracht zu verkaufen
es ist ein typisches Marktverhalten wo
es einfach darum geht sein sein Gewinn
zu maximieren oder sagen wir zu
optimieren und in diesem Falle würde es
sich wahrscheinlich nicht lohnen Mengen
anzulandten in Europa denn der
Großhandelspreis für Gas fast auf vor
krisenniveau doch für die Verbraucher
ändert sich erstmal wenig
Bestands und grundversorgungskunden
müssen weiter mit steigenden Preisen
rechnen weil die fallenden
Großhandelspreise erst zeitverzögert bei
Verbrauchern ankommen das heißt obwohl
die Preise am Weltmarkt gerade sinken
dauert es eine Weile bis ich das
durchsetzt und Verbraucher dann
tatsächlich das auch auf die Rechnung
sehen zu welchen Konditionen LNG
zukünftig eingekauft werden kann noch
offen fest steht auf das Terminal in
Wilhelmshaven folgen noch vier weitere
um die bundesweite Energieversorgung
abzusichern
20 Prozent Gas müssen eingespart werden
sagt die Bundesnetzagentur
Privathaushalte und Gewerbe übertreffen
die Vorgabe aktuell deutlich minus 45
Prozent mehr zahlen dazu in unsere ZDF
heute App
seit Jahren kennen die Immobilienpreise
nur eine Richtung immer nach oben die
Nachfrage war hoch auch weil die Kredite
wegen der niedrigen Zinsen günstig waren
doch das ändert sich gerade zum ersten
Mal seit zwölf Jahren sinken die Preise
für Häuser und Wohnungen im dritten
Quartal um 0,7 Prozent der Grund immer
weniger können sich das Bauen und kaufen
leisten und das hat auch Auswirkungen
für Mieter Eva Maria Elias und Anna
Gürth berichten
der Traum vom Eigenheim vor drei Jahren
schien er für Familie Golly aus
Pfedelbach in der Nähe von Heilbronn
noch ganz nah nur kam dann Corona jetzt
die Energiekrise und dann ist es
natürlich ein ganz ganz weite Ferne
gerückt weil ich denke heute können wir
eigentlich froh sein wenn man einen Job
haben und einfach die Miete bezahlen
können die Inflation steigt die
Kaufkraft sinkt auch im
Immobilienbereich weniger Menschen
können sich ein Haus oder eine
Eigentumswohnung leisten verstärkt wird
das durch deutlich gestiegene
Kreditzinsen so geht die Nachfrage
zurück und die Preise fallen doch
günstiger kaufen das geht angesichts der
Zinsen derzeit nur mit viel Eigenkapital
zu den teuren Krediten kommen hohe
Materialkosten mit Folgen für
potenzielle Häuslebauer wir mussten zur
Kenntnis nehmen dass gerade zu Beginn
des Jahres eine regelrechte
stornierungswelle auf die Bauwirtschaft
zukam wir rechnen und haben gerechnet
mit etwa 25 Prozent wenn weniger gebaut
und gekauft wird beeinflusst das den
Mietmarkt diejenigen Haushalte die jetzt
vorhatten zu kaufen und die aber den
Kauf nicht mehr bezahlen können auch die
drängen auf den Mietwohnungsmarkt das
heißt der Mietwohnungsmarkt wird noch
enger und damit auch teurer statt Miete
das eigene Häuschen abbezahlen für die
gollys bleibt das erstmal nur ein Traum
ja und jetzt Fußball Nationalmannschaft
Norbert morgen ist das letzte Testspiel
vor der WM ja im Oman gegen den Oman
Bundestrainer haben sie fliegt muss
hinten auf Antonio Rüdiger und vorne auf
Thomas Müller verzichten beide sind
angeschlagen möglicherweise bekommen
Neulinge und Rückkehrer im Kader ihre
erste Chance
die Generalprobe im sultanstadion steht
unter dem Motto ausprobieren und testen
aufgrund der Personalsituation wird
hanseflick den Einheimischen
Journalisten noch nicht seine WM
Startelf präsentieren können viele
Stammspieler erhalten eine Pause und die
immer noch angeschlagenen Rüdiger und
Müller werden sogar noch bis Samstag
fehlen oh letztlich geht es darum dass
wir alle möglichst auf auf dem gleichen
Niveau dann auch wenn es darum geht
unser auf Japan vorzubereiten dann an
Bord haben und so ist unseren Plan jetzt
aktuell ob fliegt mit Neuling Niklas
Füllkrug in der Startelf oder als Joker
plant ist offen doch die Chancen dass
der Stürmer von Werder Bremen seine
länderspielpremiere feiern wird stehen
gut
fußball-superstar Cristiano Ronaldo will
das portugiesische Team zum WM Titel
führen und übt in einem Interview
harsche Kritik an seinem Arbeitgeber
Manchester United das Tischtuch zwischen
ihm und seinem ehemaligen Herzensverein
das scheint zerschnitten
Weg aus Manchester wollte er schon im
Sommer das Interview jetzt vor der Reise
zur WM klingt wie eine Abrechnung
ja ich fühle mich verraten von
Manchester United Trainer Eric ten Haag
der ihn schon mal auf die Bank setzte
respektiere er nicht sagt er weil der
ihn auch nicht respektiere und von
Ex-Coach Ralf Rangnick hätte sowieso
nichts das ist not even dieser Code ist
nicht einmal Trainer wie kannst du dann
der Boss von Manchester United sein das
überraschte mich der Verein hält sich
bedeckt lässt die Kritik erst einmal
unkommentiert verklingen
nothing es hat sich hier nichts geändert
der Fortschritt hier ist gleich null
Ronaldos Vertrag bei United endet im
nächsten Jahr wenn es dabei bleibt
wie lange das noch gut gehen soll
zwischen den beiden diesen Verein und
Ronaldo schauen wir mal du wirst
berichten
alle Jahre wieder im Herbst wird der
Himmel zur Bühne angekündigt durch
lautes schnattern
[Applaus]
die majestätischen Kraniche machen in
Deutschland Station wie hier am
Goldenstedter Moor auch Sie bemerken
dass sich das Klima wandelt ein Teil
versucht sogar in Norddeutschland zu
überwintern kommt dennoch ein
Kälteeinbruch fliegen sie weiter
es wird kühler draußen und zuvor erstmal
nass mehr zum Wetter hat gleich östen
terli Christian Sievers freut sich auf
Sie im heute-journal um viertel vor zehn
und hier übernimmt morgen Jana pareigis
Ihnen alles Gute und einen schönen Abend
noch auf Wiedersehen
[Musik]
schönen guten Abend und herzlich
willkommen zum Wetter wir haben sehr
Zeit mit einem sehr umfangreichen hoch
über Skandinavien zu tun und das
blockiert den Weg der Tiefs die müssen
teilweise nach Norden ausweichen und wir
sehen dass sich da eine Luftmassengrenze
etabliert quer über Deutschland das
bedeutet viele Wolken und Regen und das
vor allem in der kommenden Nacht das
kann durchaus kräftiger sein zeitweise
nach ostenden ist es trocken teilweise
aufgelockert und Richtung Bayern vor
allem Richtung Donau bildet sich wieder
Nebel dort kalt bis ein Grad und 10 Grad
ganz im Westen am Niederrhein morgen
dann im Tagesverlauf weitere Wolken die
sich nach Osten verlagern das ist diese
Luftmassengrenze die dann auch hier
liegen bleibt es regnet teilweise
kräftig und an der Nordsee wird es
windig sein ansonsten
sich das auf von Westen her und die
Sonne zeigt sich auch mal Temperaturen
bis 15 Grad am wärmsten am Niederrhein
und sieben Grad Richtung Vogtland zum
Beispiel die nächsten Tage bleiben das
weiter Regen kommt diese
Luftmassengrenze bleibt uns erhalten
vier bis 16 Grad am Donnerstag und am
Samstag deutlich kühler im Osten bei 0
Grad ein schönen Abend